Salut Romain, dis donc t'es pour ou contre la violence toi ? [Bah je suis contre.] Bah ouais.
Mais pourquoi en fait ? [Bah parce que la violence c'est mal.]
Ouais.
Mais pourquoi exactement ? [Bah parce que c'est mal.]
Ouais, ça s'défend.
La violence c'est mal voilà. Bon normalement vous êtes tous plus ou moins au courant.
Ok, presque tous ... Mais au delà du principe moral est ce que en termes de santé vous savez pourquoi la violence c'est mal ?
Eh bah d'abord parce que la violence ça fait mal [Captain Obvious]
Mais surtout parce que la violence ça fait du mal.
Je vais essayer d'être plus clair ... Alors bien sûr quand on pense à la violence on pense : œil au beurre noir
nez cassés, hématomes, béquilles, fractures, blessures en tous genres et toutes les séquelles qui vont avec.
Rien que ça abîmer le corps de quelqu'un en le frappant, c'est moyen cool.
C'est même complètement nul mais on va se concentrer sur un organe en particulier, probablement le plus sensible aux coups violents : le cerveau.
Le système nerveux autonome celui qui gère le cœur,  la respiration,  la digestion etc ...
Il peut réagir à une douleur violente. Dans ces cas là il a tendance à s'emballer un peu, il fait ralentir les battements du cœur,
il dilate les vaisseaux donc la tension  chute
résultat votre cerveau est moins bien irrigué, il manque d'oxygène et bim vous perdez connaissance. Ça c'est valable pour
n'importe quel type de douleur.
Ça marche même pour les émotions fortes. On appelle ça une syncope ou un malaise vagal
mais c'est pas tellement que ça que j'avais envie de vous parler. quand on prend un coup au visage ou même sur la tête
il y a la douleur évidemment mais il y a aussi un autre phénomène qui rentre en jeu le prenez pas mal hein mais
votre cerveau il prend pas toute la place dans votre crâne du coup en cas de choc violent ça remue là dedans
ce qui se passe c'est que les ondes de choc se propagent de la surface du cerveau
jusque dans ses parties profondes et que ça peut se ressentir sur les fonctions qu'il est censé assurer en temps normal :  c'est ce qu'on appelle
une commotion cérébrale. Si les structures du cerveau sont trop secouées elles n'assument plus leur rôle correctement et là aussi on peut perdre connaissance
d'ailleurs si vous êtes témoin de ce genre de scène sachez que tout coup sur la tête et bah ça s'appelle un
traumatisme crânien mais surtout en cas de perte de connaissance ça vaut
vraiment le coup de passer un coup de fil au 15, au 18, ou au 112 pour aller regarder d'un peu plus près à
l'hôpital et là on parlait des coups mais c'est valable pour n'importe quel choc au niveau de la tête
alors vous me direz ça va tomber dans les pommes deux minutes c'est pas méchant
ça témoigne quand même de la violence du choc subi par le cerveau qui peut avoir des conséquences
beaucoup plus graves mais oui  parce que votre petit cerneaux de noix aux abats si ça ressemble vachement un cerneau de noix
on en a même déjà parlé
votre petit cerneau de noix donc en plus d'être secoué il peut se cogner contre les parois de la boîte crânienne et comme votre crâne
c'est de l'os donc c'est dur donc ça peut abîmer le cerveau ça peut saigner à différents niveaux ce qui est jamais une bonne nouvelle
et ça peut gonfler un peu comme quand vous cogné le genou on appelle ça un oedème cérébral sauf que
on en a déjà parlé dans la vidéo sur l'AVC vous suivez pas je suis pas content le crâne
on a vu ces de l'os donc c'est dur,  mais surtout c'est pas extensible, c'est pas élastique.
Donc si ça saigne ou si ça gonfle le cerveau il se retrouve
comprimé le sang circule moins bien et ça l’abîme encore plus. Le problème c'est que ces trucs là ça peut arriver super vite
genre dans les heures qui suivent mais ça se voit pas forcément tout de suite
Mais j'insiste, le meilleur indice c'est la fameuse perte de connaissance au moment du choc donc faut vraiment prendre ça au sérieux
Il faut prendre ça au sérieux parce que dans les cas les plus graves
les saignements les œdèmes, eh bah ça peut entraîner la mort et parfois très rapidement genre en une nuit.
T'es dans un bar tu prends un coup de poing tu rentres chez toi tu te couches
le lendemain tu t'réveille, t'es mort. C'est évidemment pas les cas les plus fréquents
mais j'en ai quand même rencontrés quand je travaillais à l'hôpital
donc faites gaffe. Et quand il tue pas un choc au cerveau, même léger, ça peut entraîner un certain nombre de séquelles
et encore plus quand ça se répète régulièrement. C'est la raison pour laquelle au rugby par exemple on a mis en place un protocole
"commotion" qui oblige tous les joueurs qu'on pris un coup à la tête à se faire évaluer tout de suite par un médecin avec éventuellement une
mise au repos forcé en cas de perte de connaissance. Parce que quand le cerveau est malmené de façon
répétée il peut apparaître qu'on appelle une encéphalopathie traumatique
chronique. Une étude récente a montré que malgré leur casque la quasi-totalité des footballeurs américains pro ont des dommages cérébraux
après l'arrêt de leur carrière. Avec des conséquences comme des troubles de la concentration des troubles du comportement
dès démence précoces des dépressions voir des suicides. Dans le cas de Mohamed Ali la légende de la boxe
de nombreux spécialistes ont fait le lien entre la maladie parkinson qu'il a développée à 42 ans seulement
et les chocs répétés qu'il a pris au niveau de la tête pendant toute sa carrière et qui ont endommagé
ses cellules nerveuses
dans un autre registre des signes
d'encéphalopathie traumatique chronique ont aussi été repérées chez les footballeurs. Oui
ils ont un cerveau ça va deux secondes les blagues et dans leur cas c'est juste le jeu de tête qu'est mis en cause,
donc vraiment un choc au niveau du visage de la tête ou du crâne c'est pas anodin.
Et pourtant, certains sites de self défense n'hésite pas à balancer la liste des points vitaux qu'on peut frapper au niveau de la tête
avec les bons gros dommage qu'on peut espérer causer si on vise bien.
Tranquille. Tu veux obtenir des grenades surdimensionnées ?
Apprends à détruire le cerveau des gens d'un simple coup d'poing
Alors bien sûr plus le choc est violent comme en cas d'une chute ou d'un accident de la route
plus les chocs sont fréquents et plus le risque est élevé mais un truc super important à retenir c'est que pour provoquer des lésions cérébrales,
voir pour tuer quelqu'un un, seul coup peut suffire
C'est déjà arrivé. Et comme vous n'avez sans doute ni envie de tuer quelqu'un ni envie de vivre avec ça sur la conscience
ni de passer plusieurs années à y réfléchir dans deux trois mètres carrés bah le mieux c'est de ne pas frapper les gens
DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo d'ici là
prenez soin de votre cerveau et de celui des autres mettez vous bien et surtout
portez vous bien. -Outro-
(Les créateurs des sous-titres sont des bénévoles, leurs noms apparaissent dans la description.)